[Music]
hey everybody
as your resident astrophysicist i'm duty
bound to alert you that on the evening
of november 18th 2021 into the wee hours
of november 19th 1am eastern time the
full moon in space in its orbit around
earth will enter earth's shadow
earth shadow is always there you don't
know it until something lit up by the
sun begins to disappear behind it
so we call that a lunar eclipse there'll
be a lot of hype people been loving full
moons lately so that'll get attention
but these things happen slowly
and it takes hours typically and there's
nothing really spectacular about it so i
must tell you that it's
boring
it's the most boring thing
i have ever experienced looking up at
the night sky i just thought i'd tell
you maybe i shouldn't even be making
this video never mind
[Music]